of all the changes that Judgment Day
brought to the Terminator Universe
perhaps none have been more impactful
than the development of Sarah Connor
originally a scared young woman fighting
for her life T2 turns Sarah into a
badass Warrior who is hellbent on
protecting her son and preventing the
apocalypse played by Linda Hamilton
Sarah's relentlessness proves time and
again to be one of her greatest
strengths and that includes the film's
final showdown when this happens get out
of the way
John John
shoot to achieve this double Sarah
effect Linda Hamilton's twin sister
Leslie arrived on set with the pair
appearing together in a single shot this
earned Leslie a seat beside her sister
at the film's Hollywood premere not to
mention a spot in Terminator history